la jornada comenzó muy temprano a las
ocho y media en el Palacio de la moneda
con un consejo de gabinete del nuevo
gabinete en la segunda gran cambio de
gabinete del presidente Gabriel boric
que se convierte así también en el
presidente que cambia a más ministros en
su primer año de gobierno fue una
jornada intensa en la que también hubo
un receso marcado por un baño de
multitudes que había acudido a la moneda
a felicitar o a adherir a mostrar su
soporte su apoyo al presidente Gabriel
Boris Qué pasó una hora aproximadamente
saludando a personas cercanas que le
mostraron su cariño hay que decir que
del otro lado de la Alameda del otro
lado de la moneda también se
manifestaban aquellos contrarios a la
gestión presidencial eran bastantes pero
menos que los que mostraban su apoyo a
Boris después de eso el presidente
realizó una reunión con los
subsecretarios Porque es importante
señalar que no solo cambiaron cinco
ministros sino 15 su secretarías aunque
los subsecretarios no tienen un rol
público tan importante Así que son muy
muy destacados en el papel que juegan en
la escena política el presidente realizó
un discurso para ellos en el que destacó
la importancia de mejorar la gestión del
gobierno A qué se refiere con esto a
mejorar la inexperiencia que ha
caracterizado Este primer año de
gobierno por personas que no tienen
tanto bagaje institucional en El
Ejecutivo y que ha marcado algunos
errores No forzados en esa línea va
también el cambio de gabinete que
realizó el viernes el presidente boric y
Patricia precisamente Cuáles son las
prioridades de Cara a este segundo año
de gobierno con este gabinete
reestructurado como usted decía
Pues seguimos en la moneda un nuevo logo
con una nueva es una nueva frase que va
a marcar este segundo año de gobierno
presentes para un futuro mejor es algo
que recalcó también mucho boric el estar
ahora presente y el realizar y tomar una
serie de medidas difíciles No
necesariamente populares pero que vayan
a marcar un mejor futuro para las
chilenos en ese en esa línea se marcan
tres ejes fundamentales la reforma de
las pensiones algo que lleva a largo
tiempo siendo esperado por los chilenos
que viven de forma indigna manifestó el
propio presidente este sábado una vez
más es algo que ya había dicho en el
pasado de la importancia de conseguir
una buena ley de reforma de las
pensiones para que las pensiones en
Chile sean mucho más altas de lo que son
en la actualidad también un eje
antidelincuencia puesto que la seguridad
es uno de los principales factores que
se marcan en el país en este momento y
tras la reforma tras el rechazo a la
reforma tributaria que
recordemos está ligada al financiamiento
del 50% de sus reformas sociales también
se habla de un loyalty a la minería con
el que se podría conseguir dinero para
financiar precisamente todos estos
cambios sociales que ambiciona al
presidente